my favorite thing we can do now let's
book the trace in the face
the night king is coming
the dead are already here hi everyone
its charlie we're getting ready for the
big episode three Battle of Winterfell
against the night king HBO has been
hyping it up all season long getting
everybody ready for this epic battle but
the really interesting thing is is that
Connelly Hill who plays Varys on the
show has been talking about Cersei who
he thinks is a much bigger threat than
the night king in the White Walkers for
a couple different reasons which I think
he's correct about so HBO just in
typical fashion when it comes to Game of
Thrones Season 8 has been trying to
misdirect you a little bit to get you
focusing on what they think is the
obvious threat instead of what the real
threat is going to be by the end of the
season so we'll explain why that is and
why Cersei is a bigger problem than the
night king as big as the night king and
the White Walkers seem they just want
you to think that that's the biggest
threat be sure to subscribe to get all
the Game of Thrones videos if you're
brand new to the channel we're doing
that HBO now giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video obviously careful
for spoilers for everything that's
happened on Game of Thrones so far but
as of this weekend that I'm posting this
video we're getting ready for season 8
episode 3 every promo every trailer
every interview that HBO has released
with the cast has been focused on hyping
up the big Battle of Winterfell against
the night king they do this every year
for a couple different reasons season 8
even more so because it is the big final
seasons 1 they understandably want
people to notice that they're breaking a
couple of records before Emmy
nominations go out is the final season
they spent something like over a hundred
million dollars in more than a year
making these six episodes so it's
understandable that they want people to
pay attention to what they're calling
the biggest longest battle in TV history
longer than the Battle of Helm's Deep
and Lord of the Rings the two towers
which was about 40 minutes long that's
why you keep hearing people talk about
the Battle of Helm's Deep when they talk
about episode 3 episode 3 is supposed to
be one hour in 18 minutes long which is
one of the longest episodes that they've
had in the history of the show
so you imagined that maybe a little bit
less than that is the actual battle
itself so way longer than the 40-minute
helm's deep battle but to the other big
reason why they've been pushing the
night king and all the marketing is the
big villain of the season is because
they know that people expect it he is
one of the core villains of the show
regardless of what you think the real
threat is and they still want to be a
very twist driven show this late in the
game like everybody talks about the big
moments on
Game of Thrones the biggest twist like
during winds of winter in season six
when Cersei blew up the great Sept
nobody was expecting them to do
something that epic until they saw that
they were seeding that with all the wild
fire and Qyburn telling her oh we found
some more much much more so remember
Game of Thrones is a show that trades on
those big twists moments but they've
been hyping up the White Walkers in the
knight kings since season one as this
real threat literally and metaphorically
walking death that they have to stop
core operating narrative structure of
the show being set up pay off in
reversal they spend seven seasons
setting up the White Walkers is his big
threat brain gave us the stakes in the
explainer in episode two last week the
show's way of explaining the mythology
behind the night king this is what he
wants to do he wants endless night he
wants to eliminate man as a species the
next step in that narrative would be to
pay off that setup which is what this
big battle is going to be during episode
three presumably obviously big twist
within each episode I don't think that
the battle with the Nike is going to end
with episode three but even then in the
grand scheme of things Jon Snow Daenerys
eventually defeats said night king it
just probably won't happen during
episode three but it'll eventually
happen later this season but eventually
they do defeat him that shouldn't mean
that they've saved the realm right
because the payoff to killing the night
king is that is supposed to end the
threat to the realm but here's the thing
it doesn't though big twist because the
next step in that narrative is the
reversal setup payoff reversal the
reversal is the surprise twist you never
saw coming or maybe you did see it
because you were expecting them to do
this in this case the reversal is Cersei
becomes a bigger problem for the realm
than the night king was for a couple
reasons one being she's created so much
chaos while Jon Snow and Daenerys are
still trying to fight the night king
Cersei is making things way harder than
they need to be by double-crossing them
not sending the extra Lannister soldiers
she promised then turning around taking
out a massive loan from the iron bank
putting the crown back into serious debt
only to use that money to hire 20,000
golden company mercenaries to destroy
any of Jon Snow and Daenerys those
forces that just happen to survive the
night King in the White Walkers during
this episode three battle on top of that
she set Bronn to the task of killing
Tyrion and Jaime using the crossbow the
Tyrion used to kill Tywin during season
four
I've already made a few death
predictions about the big characters in
Episode three but regardless of which
big characters they decide to kill off
the White Walkers are gonna carve down
most of their armies standing there so
much so the Cersei will have an
overwhelming advantage even though she
only has the golden company in her
Lannister forces remember she also has
the extra Lannister troops that she did
not send north so even though there are
only 20,000 golden company members and
no elephants much to her chagrin there's
still those extra Lannister soldiers she
has she also has Chi burns giant
scorpions for killing Daenerys is
remaining two dragons she doesn't know
about the night king having Viserion yet
but there's also probably still more
wild by her hidden underneath King's
Landing she's probably kept the
pyromancers busy even if she did burn up
most of the mad Kings wildfire that he
had hid under King's Landing during
Robert's rebellion her new weapon might
be the scorpion is even in the intro
they go down into King's Landing beneath
the Iron Throne and you see that giant
scorpion pointing at balerion the black
dread they really want you to remember
that she has those scorpions but her
real main weapon this whole time has
been wildfire and her ability to make
the worst possible decision for the
realm at any given time which means pots
falling which means fire inside the
walls which means the poor is trying to
defend the city and not burning it down
we have been working tirelessly day and
night ever since your royal sister
commanded us to do so the contents of
this room could lay King's Landing low
so even though the night King is more of
a traditional threat to the realm Cersei
is an even bigger problem right now the
advantage that Jon Snow and Daenerys
have over the night king that they do
not have over Cersei is that the night
King just has numbers in his favour he
has a lot of special abilities he has
vissarion but he has the ability to
raise the dead so he can exponentially
grow his forces during the battle as
things get worse and worse the more of
their forces that he kills the more that
he can add to his army the thing that
Cersei has that the knight King does not
have is intimate knowledge of all the
northern forces all the big players the
main characters she has a lot more info
about how to twist the knife so to speak
and given the opportunity I think that
she's sooner burned them all Mad King
style than give up the Iron Throne to
Daenerys and Jon Snow she'll do anything
she can to keep her
on the Iron Throne regardless of what's
left of the realm after the night King
so I realized that's ignoring a lot of
the relationship politics that are going
on between John Snow and Daenerys right
now Sansa in Daenerys over the fate of
the north after the battle that all just
happened during episode two but all that
is unimportant
until they deal with the night king then
deal with Cersei and there is no
scenario in all this where the realm is
better off with Cersei on the Iron
Throne
if she's ruthless and calculating now
because she thinks she's fighting for
this baby of hers she's growing the
belongs to Jaime that you're on thinks
is going to be his eventually this
second chance she keeps talking about is
a chance for us to start over before
Jaime left her how mad is she going to
go when she loses the baby probably
later this season and metaphorically has
nothing left a ruthless person with
nothing left to lose and near unlimited
resources thanks to high interest loans
from the iron bank is way worse for them
than the night king the funny thing in
all this too is that it seems like at
the end of all this the iron bank sounds
like kind of a villain to for being such
an enabler and being so quick to put the
realm back into super debt like would
you like another loan we're really happy
taking your interest money please take
as long as you like paying this back we
really love those high interest payments
you're making on this even funnier
they're not gonna forgive those loans
when the war is over so Jon Snow
Daenerys wind up winning the day they're
still gonna have to repay all of Circe's
debt that she took out because it's the
Crown's dead just like Cersei had to
repay all of Robert Baratheon's debt
that Littlefinger helped put him in
during the course of his reign so let me
know in the comments beyond trying to
get rid of Tyrion Jaime in the northern
army
what other epically crazy things do you
think that Cersei is going to do towards
the end of the season to try and keep
herself on the Iron Throne while they're
also trying to deal with the night king
think about it more from the perspective
of how she can make their situation
worse like as bad as it is trying to
fight the army of the dead the night
King the White Walkers
you also have Cersei trying to destroy
you at every single turn I also think
from a payoff perspective at the end of
the season it also makes more sense that
they hype Cersei up as the real villain
of the show just because Game of Thrones
is a show that trades on betrayal the
whole concept of a game of Thrones is
all about people betraying other people
for the Iron Throne so
course there are probably going to be
several more huge betrayals between the
characters before the show is done I
think the thing that people aren't
expecting though is that there'll be
some betrayal within Jon Snow and
Daenerys as forces so that'll be really
interesting to see the last couple of
episodes so don't be surprised if there
are some big twists during the episode
three big battle this weekend but
obviously my episode 3 video will post
after the episode airs on Sunday night
and I'll keep the giveaway open til
Monday when I post my episode 4 trailer
video the really cool thing about the
next couple of episodes - is that miguel
zapata nick originally said that they
wanted him to do episode three four in
five and he was like there's no way i
can handle that because he's mostly
known for doing their big battle
episodes like hardhome in battle of the
bastards so that's why you're seeing him
- episode 3 in episode 5 so i wouldn't
be surprised if there's another big
battle during episode 5 but i don't
think it's gonna be quite as big as the
battle during episode 3 the way they've
been hyping it up so everybody just get
hype while you wait for everything click
here for my season 8 episode 3 trailer
video and click here for my season 8
episode 2 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome i'll see
you guys tonight